[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between subway in the uk and the us
this is food wars
the subway in the uk you can get
sandwiches in four different sizes
firstly we have toasted bites
a six inch sub
a foot long sub
and
then
you can get a platform
and in the us we have three sizes the
six inch
the footlong
yeah you go for you and your team
ah the big boy
party platter the old subway platypus
now in the uk a platter looks like this
what they do is they make four foot long
sandwiches then they cut those into
fours so you're left with 16 pieces each
of which is three inches and for the
party platter here they take five
sandwiches cutting them into three
pieces giving you 15 sandwiches total in
addition in the u.s you can also get
yourself
a three
foot long party sub
look at this thing this is ridiculous
uh three feet so that is
what's that in what do you got in the uk
it's 17 meters
i have no idea
yeah
now in the uk drinks at subway come in
two sizes
we have a regular which is 400
milliliters
20 ounce spray it would up and we have a
large
30 ounce
boom
if you're really thirsty
40
ounces of soda
40 ounces is a little over three cans of
soda
that is way too much soda
this is way too much just too much
if you're a fan of subways cookies in
the uk those come in three sizes
one cookie
three cookies
four
12 cookies
in the u.s subway you can get
a single cookie
a dozen cookies right like that
or
the
hang on keep rolling
the
36 cookie platter booyah
[Laughter]
i'm like in vegas baby all in
we want to make sure that you're getting
the same amount of filling as you do in
the us here in the uk so what we've got
here is a foot long italian bmt on
hearty italian with lettuce and olives
we're going to weigh it to see if the
quantities are the same
all right bmp
so the weights are pretty similar what
we're going to do is take them apart and
see how it all adds up
so when it comes to the amount of
filling that you get in your subs it
looks like the uk and the us are
actually pretty identical
so what about calories we found out that
the most popular sub at subway is
actually the turkey breast sub so if you
were to walk into a uk subway and order
a regular turkey breast sub and then
making a meal by including a regular
drink and a cookie you'd be looking at
621 calories
that same order in the u.s is 690
calories
now the sub itself is actually less
calories it's only 250 but the drink the
medium coke is around 240 and the cookie
is 200 calories but wait according to
the internet in the us the default
actually comes with
two cookies which brings it to a grand
total of 890 calories
what about the calories in another sub
well in the uk six inches of meatball
marinara comes in at 492 calories in the
u.s six inch meatball is only 430
calories yo now because we're not sure
why our meatball serve is more calorific
we're actually going to do another test
we're going to bring back our friend the
scales
and we're going to weigh a meatball
let's just
clean up
delicious
boom
and now i will also weigh
one meatball
i find a good one
don't want the sauce to
throw off these measurements getting
real close get in real close over there
ready you close
close here we go
drum roll
and
how much is it
no change
our scale is not very accurate
sorry
let's get that weight up on the screen
unfortunately subway in the uk doesn't
disclose a full ingredients list however
there are some things we can glean from
the website in the uk the ham turkey
breast and steak that you'll find in
your sandwiches are actually formed the
turkey bologna and the turkey salami are
also made by a process known as
mechanically separated turkey
mechanical
[Music]
from the allergens list in the uk we can
also see that our meatballs contain milk
although it's not clear if the meatballs
contain the milk or if it just comes
with cheese by default we do have the
ingredients list of the meatball
sandwich at subway and i'll read that to
you right now
oh boy beef water bread crumbs and then
we have the kind of square brackets
toasted wheat crumbs and now we have the
curved brackets enriched wheat flour now
we have the fancy brackets wheat flour
niacin reduced iron thiamine mino mono
nitrate riboflavin folic acid close
fancy brackets sugar salt soybean oil
yeast let me close the other two
brackets aha textured soy protein
concentrate seasoning open brackets
again
dehydrated onion and garlic salt spices
dehydrated parsley soybean oil close
brackets uh soy protein concentrate and
the romano cheese can you scroll up
please
keep going keep going
the romano cheese which is made from
pasteurized part skin cow's milk ugh
i'm assuming it's skim cow's milk but to
be honest if i told you there was cow
skin in this food would you be surprised
part skim cow's milk cheese cultures
salts and enzymes which enzymes you ask
they're not at liberty to say but rest
assured there are enzymes now on the
bright side the dough is pretty much
normal for the classic italian bread the
ingredients are enriched flour which is
wheat flour niacin reduced iron thymine
mino nitrate nitrate yeah okay
riboflavin folic acid water yeast sugar
soybean oil salt wheat gluten cultured
wheat flour malted barley flour
sunflower lechathan lecithin lecathon
hey did you hear that
lecithin lecithin sunflower lecithin
dough conditioner which also has enzymes
which ones you know now and ascorbic
acid
all that stuff
while we might not have an ingredients
list for our bread we do know that it's
likely to not be perfect for example an
irish court recently declared that
subway cannot call its loaves bread due
to the high sugar content subway uses
more than 10 percent sugar in their
flour
here's everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk subway so let's start
with the subs now there are a few kind
of default subs that you can only find
in the uk so then once you've chosen
your sub and your bread we've also got a
few other customization options that are
exclusive to the uk for example in this
sub we've combined a bunch of them so
i've gone for chicken tikka it has hash
browns it has sweet corn it has vegan
garlic aioli it has hp brown sauce and
it has whole grain mustard so brown
sauce is kind of a traditional british
condiment the biggest brand manufacturer
of it is a brand called hp which stands
for houses of parliament to maybe give a
nod harry
are you really brit-splaining to me hp
sauce i love hp sauce i've been i've
been having hp sauce had a bottle of hp
sauce in my fridge for at least the past
20 years over here we have the meatless
meatball marinara sub with some vegan
mozzarella cheese as well and it's on
chili paprika bread our exclusive
customizations in the u.s include
avocado pepper jack cheese provolone
swiss cheese and banana peppers if you
like your sauce you can make your sauce
if you like a saucy sub you can have the
sauciest subway saucy sub here in the
united sauce because we have all these
sauces including a balsamic sub sauce a
creamy sriracha a deli brown mustard
yellow mustard you guys don't have
yellow mustard
that can't be right
sorry if you have yellow mustard i
thought that was everywhere uh oil
oil
you guys don't have oil either
okay
uh subway herb and garlic oil ranch red
wine vinaigrette and a special sub spice
so moving the subs to one side for a
second
we also have some side dishes which are
exclusive to the uk
let's start with this which kind of
surprised me when i saw it on the menu
but you can actually just get a cup of
meatballs from subway next we have the
garlic cheesy bread which i think is
just half of their hearty italian six
inch
with some garlic butter on it and then
they kind of sprinkle some cheese on top
and throw it in the toaster oven
the last side dish is nachos they
actually just get some doritos throw
them into a box give you some cheese
some jalapenos
that is an insult to nachos those are
the kind of nachos you make in your 20s
when you're drunk at two in the morning
chips cheese microwave it throw on some
salsa that is the most depressing plate
of notches ever seen
that is the worst thing associated
excuse me that is the second worst thing
associated with the subway franchise the
only exclusive side that you can get at
a subway in the u.s is the applesauce
pouch which
we don't have unfortunately the two
subways we went to did not have them
available could we get a
graphic of the um applesauce pouch on
the screen somewhere near my head
yeah it looks like that now we wanted to
get as many uk exclusives into one sub
as possible so
this is my creation i'll be clear this
is not my usual order
you've got the tang of the brown sauce
with the little popping sweetness of the
sweet corn
and i just got like a whole hash brown
in there as well do not order the uk
only sub
and of course
we put together a sub with all the usa
only ingredients which is a foot long
barbecue rib sandwich with the jalapeno
cheddar bread and avocado and pepper
jack cheese and provolone cheese and
swiss cheese and banana peppers ah the
us with banana peppers i don't know what
are things with banana peppers
i'm not into banana peppers i don't know
why they're so popular here
that's actually pretty good
i actually like that
the jalapeno bread
wow
oh man the sriracha sauce ooh and the
avocado well it's got some heat to it
too
i'm totally surprised i kind of like
that
[Music]
you